you know Sean Gunn good friend of both
of ours he was on the podcast yeah yeah
and he you know Iike us worked together
in guardians I think Suicide Squad
whatever he says I loved your interview
with Rooker the first time cuz he got
real he got a little you know I'm not
emotional but like and I was like really
I said huh he he went on about it he
doesn't know what he's talking about
doesn't know he's talk no I know you had
you have a grandkid something kids yeah
I got two girls did did you cry when
they were born know that a happiness no
like it's a question ever why would I
cry yeah crying give me a break
yeah geez I mean your wife misses
Rooker's seen you mr. Rooker emotional
have you ever been emotional you're
hiding are you a cry don't cry don't cry
why big why should I cry I know you were
a tough kid growing up you had a lot of
[ __ ] go crying here there's no crime
yeah you know we don't do no crying yeah
it's matter with you you say that's your
grandkids hey stop the crying I bet
you're a lovable little nah come on
hey no crying what what makes Rooker's
heart just Oh what makes his heart just
he just completely melts what have none
I don't have a hot [ __ ] my heart there's
some and there is no there's something
inside you that when something happens
some you you melt it's it's one thing to
see well there's certain things when I
you know when I I don't know sometimes
if I do charity work or if I have a
connection or someone I could cry I
could open up a little bit yeah not not
easily it's it's it's come out more its
life so it happens that doesn't matter
well it happens whenever it happens
what's the last time it happened you're
driving from Wisconsin in your new truck
I cried during love scenes you know what
scenes whatever scenes when I'm watching
a movie and there's something's
emotional like why I
I am chloride blend in with the actors
and I'm there and I see it and and it's
emotional and especially especially if
if it you know if they're doing a good
job the actors I saw you in the premiere
in the galaxy - when yondu dies yeah and
I looked over you were like in the row
in front of me because you were one of
the stars and I had a small role but I
looked over and you were just yet tears
in your eyes I did you did I remembered
you remember obviously you know I was
like I just can't let go because I
thought it was a great moment I look at
you to see how you were responding to
your performance of yahoodi' and I could
see you were emotional and there are no
tears though I didn't see tears I was a
little far no tears yeah I I had just
had some onions you know what was going
through your mind when that happened
like this is such a sick boobie snack of
onions you know I wasn't really thinking
too much about that
when yondu dies I wasn't thinking about
when yondu dies I'm I'm yondu in the
scene so I don't I'm not thinking about
I'm dying what I was thinking of what
you're thinking hey this is really the
end of guardians for me so no I wasn't
thinking that at all what do you think
just watch I wasn't thinking anything
you just actors great I just doing the
scene that was it yeah no I meant when
you're watching yondu yeah yeah are you
talking about yeah you're watching
you're watching the scene you're
watching yondu so you're just watching
the movie yeah you were able to step
outside you just watch yourself as an
actor play this blue character yeah
although I'm a little bit when I watch
scenes and things that I'm doing
I'm always one
ring
I don't know if I could do that better
that was that was as great as I could
possibly be great at you know that's a
great feeling
you know I normally go well I sort of
been better sometimes oh no no I I have
encountered times when I go that that
needed to have this we didn't get it I
didn't quite get it no I never do
anything ever ever ever that I don't get